Looking for work?
This is how to score a job
interview at the SCP Foundation!
Enjoy dealing with interesting people on
the job? Do you love the idea of every
day at work possibly being your last? If
so, then we may have a position for you!
Wanna be a researcher?
]Pick an esoteric scientific field
and then rise to the top of it, before
developing an obsession with studying
the supernatural. You’ll get laughed out of
academia, and right into an SCP Containment Site!
Wanna be a guard or an MTF Member?
Become a stone-cold military badass,
get the rest of your team
tragically killed by an anomaly,
and start seeking revenge until the
Foundation decides to let you go pro!
Wanna be a member of the O5 Council?
See to it that one of the current
members “disappears”, that seems
to work like a charm! Good Luck!
Wanna be a D-Class?
Oh, that’s easy - Just commit
a series of pretty horrific murders,
seek the death penalty at your trial,
and say “Yes” if any mysterious men
in white coats offer you a way out.
Note: SCP Explained absolutely DOES NOT endorse
committing a series of pretty horrific murders
or any kind of murders whatsoever.
We’re just talking jokes here, folks,
and if you say otherwise we’ll deny it in court.